the Joe Rogan experience well wonderboy
Thompson is an excellent example of that
exactly he fights so well with his hands
down he is to me the consummate karate
style fighter that has made the perfect
transition to MMA because he fights so
well with his hands down you don't know
where stuff's coming you don't know
whether it's coming up whether it's
coming around whether it's going
straight at you and you don't see it
until you're looking at his body and
these things are coming up from his
hands being down like this and he's
standing sideways you can take him to
the wrong trainer and ruin him let's say
he was really young and he was forbidden
that style hmm because some trainers do
that they for bread a certain style they
forbid a certain type of maneuver or or
or style out altogether like for
instance in the 70s most trainers would
not train a right hand left hand a boxer
did switch you around no no I don't
train left-handed you got to be right at
you got to convert you but that's a
that's a Dex Dexter meant to the fighter
because your trainer is limited and when
he only understands fighting in one way
now I'm gonna limit my fighter it's it's
it's totally wrong in my opinion what do
you think about fighters who say that
even if you're a right-handed person
there's an advantage to fighting as a
southpaw because you have your most
dexterous hand the hand that you have
the most control of is your lead hand
and you're also fighting in this unusual
stance that is only like what is
southpaw is like maybe 2 out of 10
people something like right right here
in the West yeah yeah if you go to Asia
it's a lot more but is it really yeah
the Asians are more Sapa I think you
know they the wheel of the cars on the
other side and there's stick shift I
don't know if like a left-handed world
almost a lot of things are the other way
around huh
yeah like they drive on the other side
of the road the the the drivers on the
other side of the car so I don't know
maybe maybe it affects the way you
developed but I agree like I think I
always tell fighters try both sides and
see which one you like better I can't
tell you which one you're more
comfortable with maybe one of your eyes
is a stronger so you're like this it's
kind of killing you so you need to be
like that you never know until you test
so I like to let the guys figure it out
so when top people tell me do I grab it
like this or like that in some instances
there's a right way in the wrong way for
as far as we know
one way is right one way is wrong and
sometimes it doesn't make a difference I
tell guys grab like you're comfortable
because I do it the way I like to do it
I don't do it the way my trainer showed
me so in this particular instance I say
it's a question of comfort like people
freak out if you grab a Kimura like this
with your thumb mm-hmm I don't in some
instances I grab the Kimura with my
thumb and some instances I don't mmm so
I just show people both and I say look
that part it's up to you you certainly
can't finish it by using the Thunder and
and some is this is stronger with a
thumb in some instances yeah because you
have better hand control sure yeah you
know just clamping down on it you're
actually isolating it yeah I mean some
people have just ridiculous
grip with their hands too and that
should play a factor in there as well do
you remember
Semmy Schilt yes so he Scheldt that had
hands they're as big as his table and
he'd grab ahold of guy's wrists and just
[ __ ] like if you were in his garden he
just grabbed your wrist yeah he did that
we feed those like then and paged it
that with the lima yes remember that yes
mm-hmm
[Applause]